you know I've been really hopeful that I
was never again going to have to mention
the name Sherry 10 Penny to you it's a
horrible name not on principle but
because of who Sherry Tenpenny is you
may or may not remember that Sherry
Tenpenny is this anti-vaccine
osteopathic physician who believes that
vaccines cause autism who previously
made all sorts of wild statements about
covid and about vaccination she is back
and she is now saying that vaccinating
children which is the next phase of
getting out of this pandemic we got to
get everybody vaccinated or as close to
everybody as possible we now can
vaccinate 5 to 11 year olds with the
Pfizer vaccine Dr Tenpenny Dr Tenpenny
is back saying that's like a late term
abortion if you give a vaccine to a kid
it's like a really really really late
term abortion now as a reminder
this is from a few months ago
here is Sherry Tenpenny saying that we
really shouldn't be afraid of covid but
she is spreading all sorts of horrible
lies about the vaccines to make people
afraid remember this this was months ago
take a look
you're thinking if there is a if you can
think of any other product in any other
industry that has killed more than 5 000
people stated in the vares database and
even if only half of those are true
22 500 deaths in six months of use and
it's still full court press full steam
ahead so it makes one have to wonder why
why are we still doing this why are we
putting people into nursing homes like
that happened in New York and put people
with with known covet into place yeah
um 10 Penny also promotes conspiracies
about 5G cell phone networks and more
let's take a listen to that
and some of the information that I think
had been discussed on your podcast
related to EMF frequencies that was a
thought and it was because now because
right now we're all kind of um
hypothesizing I mean what is it that's
actually being transmitted that's
causing all of these things is it a
combination of the protein which now
we're finding has a metal attached to it
I'm sure you've seen the pictures all
over the Internet of people who've had
these shots and now they're magnetized
and put a key on their forehead it
sticks they can put spoons and forks all
over them and they can stick because now
we think that there's a metal piece to
that there has been people who've long
suspected that there was some sort of an
interface yet to be defined an interface
between what's being injected in these
shots and all of the 5G Towers not
proven yet but we're trying to figure
out what is it that's being transmitted
to these unvaccinated people so this is
someone who has made now I don't know
about a career but she's made herself
quite prominent as a as a sort of of a
darling of the anti-vaccine and
conspiracy movement she's been against
masks even though we have scientific
peer-reviewed studies about the
effectiveness of masks she is against
vaccines she says the vaccines can kill
you they can cause autoimmune disease
that some people will die from the
vaccine directly and others are just
going to get really really sick and get
long-term diseases maybe 42 days out
maybe a year out Etc on and on and on a
sperm quality claims Etc
so now she has resurfaced at this we
how many people that we have covered
ended up at this very place the reawaken
America rally over the weekend in San
Antonio
um Michael Flynn was there
uh I think Mike pillow was there just so
many people that we follow were at this
absolutely horrible event right-wing
Pastor John Hagee uh did the event at
the Cornerstone Church in San Antonio
Texas here is ten Penny saying a lot of
crazy things dangerous things including
that giving a kid a vaccine is like an
abortion people got to start saying to
their bosses who are required them to
get tested if they don't get a shot that
you need to start saying to them torture
is illegal in the United States of
America now that will not work the
advice that ten Penny gives will not
work vaccine requirements are legal a
vaccine isn't torture you will probably
lose your job if you follow ten Penny's
advice and repeatedly testing me for
being non-compliant and disobedient
sure covet tests are not torture either
you're going to lose your job if you do
what she says I think that we're going
to be writing that up and we're going to
sending it into the EEOC C and we're
going to start accusing you and these
policies of being torture now the EEOC
is the um equal employment opportunity
Council I think I think it's that anyway
the idea that if you write to them and
say it's torture to test an employee
that the EEOC is going to get involved
it's a waste of time everything she says
is a waste of time call a spade a spade
and we know that this is Murder by
injection right and you're supposed to
give this as sacrificing your children
two
balak
child sacrifice so now as if it wasn't
off the rails before now they bring in
all of this Mark of the Beast child
sacrifice weird scriptural stuff and
resurged in these
wait a second I thought she was here as
a as an osteopathic doctor
what does ba'al have to do with that our
Babel and the descendants of nimrod and
this is what what is happening and if
you see anybody participating in this
you need to be challenging them of what
they are doing to their spirituality and
what they are sacrificing their children
to you know I had a really good friend
who said you know we've sacrificed over
60 million newborn unborn babies in
abortion we have multiple States in this
country who actually allow late-term
abortion
now we are doing very very very very
very late term abortion by killing
five-year-olds so she is saying you give
a five-year-old a vaccine
they're gonna die it's like an abortion
this is happening in America people
and it's your
map and shove it in their face and if
they defund you off of social media who
cares if they defund you off of social
media this is is this a grifter or is it
a sick woman or is it both
now it's about trying to save unborn
babies and pregnant women it's about the
they they now are actually starting a
trial and to give these shots to six
month olds
this is child sacrifice this is the
Resurgence of child sacrifice from the
days of the Babylonian Mystery Schools
as it said in Genesis 6. stand what
Jesus himself said that in those final
days it will be like as in the days of
Noah and what were they doing child
sacrifice and what else were they doing
it's funny because you know she's
presented as this great doctor ten Penny
but she flips back and forth between
speaking about her supposed medical
credentials and knowledge uh which are
shaky versus just making religious
claims where then it's like well so it's
just it's more of like a pastor then
it's not really what what does it really
matter that she's doctor 10 Penny if
what she's talking about is Noah and
Babylonians and all and all of these
different things this is a dangerous
woman
uh I don't exactly know what licensing
she's subject to it should be
investigated and it should be explored
whether she actually is worthy of that
license but the question I really
continue to Come Away with is
are we talking about a grifter here
or are we talking about a sick woman
are we talking about a liar are we
talking about someone who's confused
what is it really about I'm curious to
hear from you your internet activity and
data is being observed by a variety of
parties they're selling your information
they're deciding what you can access
don't let it happen to you I use Atlas
VPN to keep my internet traffic private
from isps Tech platforms online
marketers even governments and Atlas VPN
keeps me protected against hackers
people eavesdropping on networks to
steal your information if I turn on
Atlas VPN before logging into Netflix
Hulu or Amazon I can access streaming
content from other countries I can even
watch stuff from Argentina like soccer I
use Atlas VPN on all of my devices you
install it you turn it on once and then
you just forget about it and enjoy your
privacy you can read online about why
vpns are so important to use every day
really something you should have and
Atlas VPN is having a huge Black Friday
sale giving you 86 percent off comes out
to like a dollar 39 a month for a
subscription plus you'll get three
months free just go to
atlasv.pn slash Pacman the link is down
below